you might get your shop on hey darling
[Laughter]
[Music]
walkabouts come with me Josh Smith and
today we're joined by the kick-ass TV
presenting herself as AJ doo-doo babes I
mean you're fresh from your SAS who
dares wins challenge I've like literally
been tossed off the side of a bridge but
you know what Amir well yeah and we're
gonna set you possibly even more
trickier challenge today babe is you're
gonna have to help find the ultimate
free spring summer 2019 looks here
reserved
we are gonna shop till we drop they look
1 what are you looking for the ultimate
summer holiday look would you say I love
a 2-page because I like the versatility
of movies but it gets cold it doesn't
interfere with anything so big it's just
right up my street I'm not no but you're
getting our shoulders out
lianca loving but I love about this is
it's kind of like ambolyn for the beach
like a big sleeve I'm upset it's really
really good but what are you matching
with this just what I need to know I
need some shorts how cute are they get
those high-waisted pants are you tell me
that isn't good I'm telling you that
that's good stunning ok so for me babe
you are very at one with your personal
style and you're very confident when it
comes to dressing but how long is it
taking you to get that clothing
confidence basically as soon as I could
buy my own clothes I think that's where
I came into my own is the sixth child
out of 8
that's a law a Salah I've been brought
up on happy downs but the second I could
just popped my own tags she was away
good to go
we're on alert for it's totally amazing
festival outfit how much she loved a
festival love baseball
I'll be the festivals all the similar
right love matching GU I know who do I
make this great I mean nowadays we've
got animal print we've got crop top we
get in my belly I'm having everything to
me hello matching shorts will give we
give in high-waisted as well then how do
you accessorize for a festival somewhat
like this you know you're going into the
cart it's all a little bit bumpy but hey
it's right yeah there's a lot people out
there who don't necessarily in those
sales
what can either vice would you want to
get them what you're wearing is an
expression but it's it's not you it's
not your personality it's not your
feelings it's not your song and also
don't be so concerned about the size on
the label you know sometimes I'm a size
12 sometimes I'm a size a sometimes a
size 14 depending what I wanted to do
right doesn't matter just moving about
you know how you feel in these clubs we
are looking for the ultimate Dave
tonight lurk okay that crucial old
cornerstone of anyone's wardrobe
especially it spring/summer because
we're going out on the aren't we we are
we are during the day I am working on a
trouser and I am working on a top and
although it is you know what this is
nice it's looks it's silky it feels
luxurious you don't you can have a white
train I'm on with it or we cheat a
little here
[Music]
so it's now time to reveal the ultimate
festival look for spring/summer 19 are
you ready for the grave are you ready
for the rave I'm ready for the road
babes take me to that rave and taught me
free the left well we've gone wild
things you want to stand out at the
festival it's all about peacocking yeah
you know go home
[Music]
there she are now honey this is what I
call an update power stage
exactly she dated I wondered put on the
love here also me Hamburg for me bags
got all the essential keys for charger
makeup - oh you're giving me sunshine
I feel like I'm in the Sun these
shoulders from this top look at those
shoulders
so babe you have served up some spring
summer looks haven't you I have you want
to get these stunning spring summer
looks make sure you get down to reserved
store knock the street in London or
online right now for more inspiring and
empowering videos like this with such
amazing ethic women as this make sure
you subscribe to the glamour UK channels
now we wing
[Music]